Fatima's whole world has gone
few of her family survived
on a patch of wasteland in a broken City
they try to keep warm
as she lists the dead
mother father sisters brothers
13 lost to the rubble ten children
[Music]
eight days ago the house looked like
this
this is what remains
a home now a tomb where her loved ones
died
victims of an earthquake which keeps
playing in her mind
even when we're standing we feel like
we're shaking she says
around them Rescuers try to recover the
Dead
as the living do what they can to
survive
we heard stories of people being taken
out of the rubble that died
the freezing weather isn't the only
challenge
there's no work we are bankrupt
brother-in-law Habib says
he shows us the van where they take
turns to sleep
for me I have no hope it's over the city
is finished
at night here it's bitterly cold the
temperature dropping to minus four or
below and that will continue for weeks
this country has already experienced a
natural disaster and now it's facing a
humanitarian one
people have left adiaman in their
thousands power is Patchy the water off
or contaminated
state-made tent Villages replace homes
Aisha shows us the government-supplied
shelter she shares with 10 others they
have no toilets or showers and a growing
fear of disease
we can't deal with an outbreak now those
who survived will then die half of the
city is dead she says
turkey is now doing what it can but the
need is overwhelming the suffering
endless Siobhan Robbins Sky News adiaman
turkey